[Music]
hi hello gamespot has access to Google's
project stream for Assassin's Creed
Odyssey I'm Michael hi I'm joined by
Lisa James hi hello we go we kick things
off by running well first of all let's
go with what PC specs we're running sure
since project stream is a streaming
service to play games that Google is
trying to test out right now again this
is just a test phase for it just so you
know what we're working with we have
Intel Core i7 8700 k gtx 1070 video card
and 32 gigabytes of ram but that doesn't
really matter for the streaming service
what really matters is your internet
connection so just to give you an idea
what we're working with you role is
hitting a gig download speed all right
cool yeah oh that's pretty good Internet
so we're not foreseeing any issues when
we're actually playing the game hoping
it's gonna come out buttery smooth we'll
just wait for it to finish it yeah okay
so we're almost at a gig download speeds
and nine milliseconds of ping now these
are what's important for obviously wrote
like I said running a streaming service
so it's also important is not just
download speeds but like consistency of
that speed because you don't want speed
to be dropping in and out so we're gonna
be looking for that consistency that we
want so let's go into it I have a well
we have a controller plugged in but I
don't know if it's recognized yeah
hopefully it'll I think so what we're
looking for here is kind of visual
quality and latency with button inputs
and all that oh let's get some gameplay
audio oh man speaking of game audio okay
there we go you can hear it alright
alright so oh there we go so it's
recognized that we've got an Xbox one
controller plugged in
uh all right let's sweet go alright yeah
just so you know that there are no
graphics settings for this version of
the game because it's all it all depends
on your internet connection so I think
we're get it's gonna top off at 1080p
though yeah so there's a little stutter
there I just thought so yeah I want to
see how this would compare to like a
high-end PC and since we have high-end
internet see if those things are
comparable just through an eye test I
mean we're not gonna be doing any like
benchmarking or we're not gonna be doing
any like analysis of frame-by-frame is
smart just us getting a feel for how the
game runs see if there's any like
noticeable differences through the
beginning of AC Odyssey alright it's
pretty dope yeah it's play as a Leonidas
and chop some fools down yeah this is
like the tutorial ish mission so we're
gonna be trying to seek out if the
button inputs or any like noticeable
difference in inputs because there are
some timing important timing things in
battle like parrying it's gonna be a
real test of my parry ability yeah see
if I get ready it's way more lenient
than say Dark Souls of blood of course
you very still it's still so
theoretically if you have this speed of
it if you have this download speed and
you're running off of like a Chromebook
you could be playing this as the street
Odyssey and the way it looks right now
yeah
yeah that's it's pretty wild think about
it but yeah again that depends on your
internet speed your internet connection
consistency and also say something else
oh this is a yeah this runs through
google chrome the browser so if you when
you saw in the beginning is that since
we had access to project stream we just
hit a button and the game booted it's as
simple as that
it doesn't feel like there's any input
lack like it feels good I think the
thing I'm struggling not struggling with
but like I play on ps4 so I'm just
trying to get feels the controller feels
a little bit oh yeah cuz we're we're
using Xbox controller you can't use a
ps4 controller for AC Odyssey of the PC
version of the game I don't know if you
can use it for this particular version
of it so we're gonna have another
platform to review games on seems like
it review this on google chrome now but
also I'm curious how low times compared
to console versions and PC but i mean
from peaceful protests
oh well yes well pro like even going
between gameplay to conversation with
someone sometimes or like activating a
quest the load time will be you know
like 10 seconds okay I imagine that'll
low times will also be tied to your your
connection speed or it could be based on
whatever wherever this is server is
located because I know a NVIDIA has they
have a streaming service also GeForce
now I believe that's what it's called
and they have systems in a remote
location for which you basically mirror
gameplay off of you stab these dudes a
few times they'll survive
what pushed me back even though I I mean
there was no input lag on oh that was
great
oh that's good that's uh it's important
to know yeah as someone who's just
watching this I noticed that yeah it's
not it's not exactly 60 frames per
second I would say but visual quality
wise based on our what I'm looking at
right here it looks looks great I mean I
would say maybe this is comparable to
you know 1080p high settings on a PC but
again without the super high frame rate
that you would get if you had a high-end
machine in terms of like consoles you
said you're playing on ps4 pro how does
it compare in your eyes and in your
hands I mean it's kind of weird to
compare without having the ps4 version
like next right I mean it looks smooth
it plays really nicely it just it just
feels like I'm playing it on like how I
normally would I haven't noticed
anything huge I would be so interested
to see it at a lower intimate though
okay yeah because obviously we are very
very fortunate we have one yeah like if
if the if the bare minimum is 25
megabytes per second I definitely want
to see what that would look like but we
can't throttle our own Internet so sorry
about that yeah I can tell this is a
frame rate as little as frame rate is
consistent it's just not it's just not
not 60 yeah so I'm wondering if I know
again a project stream from Google is in
a test phase so I'm wondering if they
would open up themselves to like
different crap graphics options and then
like say here's your internet speed and
your a lot of these like is your
recommended settings if you if you have
this amount of download speed so there's
no graphic settings no graphic settings
you know it's a solely based on your
speed yeah
you need be there you go yeah I would be
curious to say like hey I want to play
it like a high preset oh but oh you're
gonna need at least fifty megabytes if
you want to run the high preset or I
want a higher framerate you'll need at
least like 70 megabytes like just as an
example I would uh I like to see that
maybe with a fuller version of the game
yeah I'm starting to notice a maybe a
little bit of compression in the overall
game where I'm looking at the trees
towards the like further out into the
environment and they they do look a
little bit less detailed as say if we're
running a PC version on high at 1080p
yeah this is yeah there's some I guess
lighting and shadow popping in and out I
mean that's not - that's not foreign
either on break done dream yeah you're
not into it like I remember being three
years ago and seeing things like Gaikai
for the first time in a year for the
first time so just to see where that's
gone and how it is now is insane to me
yeah this is it's impressive to see that
you know there's there's evidence
there's infrastructure for something
like this to where you know you you
essentially don't even need a box to run
a full triple-a game but again I know
that a lot of the restraint or the thing
that's kind of preventive for this is
like people who have data caps who don't
necessarily have like the highest
internet speeds so that is this thing
would be essentially inaccessible for
those regions that who do that have to
deal with data caps but if you don't
have that restriction I mean
this is this is something this is miss
cool and it feels great to play like it
doesn't feel like I'm battling against
the game or anything you know it feels
like I'm you're not trying you're not
having to compensate for you know laggy
timing or anything like that so yeah
it's it seems like it's it's running
competently mm-hmm
and considering that this is running off
again this is running off of Google
Chrome so it's just in the browser all
based on your internet speeds so again
like you said we're running like a core
i7 a 1070 GPU but that doesn't matter
because if we had if we had a Chromebook
in here running the same internet speeds
the experience would be identical I
guess I guess it could theoretically I
suppose unless there's like certain
restrictions on like OS is not just
maybe not just the browser so there
could be there could not be that's
something that you might want to look
more into if you're interested in
Google's project stream but ya know
there's a lot of conversations about you
know having games streamed instead of
you know BOTS I know that like for
example like PlayStation now you can
download games on PlayStation now now I
believe but for a while that was
strictly just the streaming service so
you would just stream the game straight
to your PlayStation but I mean as time
moves on the technology gets more and
more impressive and can do a lot more
like run a full triple-a game such as AC
Odyssey competently with some pretty
neat graphic settings straight off an
internet connection thank you for
watching for more on Assassin's Creed oh
to see it make sure to stay tuned to
beyond today Odyssey so yep check out
GameSpot comm for all that good stuff
i'm michael hi i'm jane bye bye
you
[Music]